fue en el vídeo pasado en el que
introdujimos la idea de interés
compuesto pero antes de haber definido
interés compuesto lo primero que
definimos fue interés por ejemplo si
nosotros invertimos 100 pesos en un
cierto banco a una tasa de interés del
10% entonces nosotros después de un año
vamos a obtener 110 pesos si la tasa de
interés es anual ahora bien para
entender la idea de interés compuesto lo
que hay que pensar es que estos 110
pesos que obtuvimos después del primer
año de haber invertido los vamos a
volver a invertir un segundo año y
después los vamos a volver a invertir un
tercer año y así sucesivamente toda la
cantidad de dinero que estemos
obteniendo en cada año y como el dinero
se está reinvirtiendo a una misma tasa
de interés eso es lo que se conoce como
interés compuesto después yo les hice
una pregunta muy interesante la pregunta
de la siguiente en cuánto tiempo con una
tasa de interés del 10% duplicamos
nuestro dinero y para eso resolvimos
esta ecuación y llegamos a que x era
igual a logaritmo en base 1.1 de 2 y
bueno vamos a resolverla primeramente
voy
el avance 1.1 porque no es muy amigable
por lo tanto voy a decir que es lo mismo
que el logaritmo en base de 10 dedos y
esto es dividido entre logaritmo de 1.1
no entre el logaritmo en base 10 de 1.1
si esto por una propiedad de 2
logaritmos y así ya lo tenemos el
logaritmo en base 10 en el logaritmo
común y corriente que nosotros conocemos
y aunque seamos muy buenos resolviendo
logaritmos no creo que sea tan sencillo
resolver este logaritmo por lo tanto
vamos a sacar la calculadora y con esta
herramienta va a ser mucho más sencillo
resolverlo entonces 2 logaritmo en base
10 que 0.30 10 ya esto hay que dividirlo
entre el logaritmo de 1.1 por lo tanto a
1.1 le sacamos el logaritmo normal y
esto nos da 0.04 13 y si hacemos la
división en total nos da 7.27 25 47
punto 27 25 vamos a notarlo esto es
aproximadamente 7.3 lo redondea para que
sea mucho más fácil tener este cálculo
porque hoy les voy a enseñar una regla
que realmente nos sirve bastante
la regla del 72 sólo quiero mencionar
que este simbolito que parecen dos olas
es el símbolo de aproximado y ya con
esto terminamos el ejercicio
aproximadamente en 7.3 años vamos a
duplicar nuestros 100 pesos a una tasa
del 10 por ciento anualmente muy bien
pero ya que estamos hablando de
aproximaciones vamos a hablar acerca de
la regla del 72 nos va a dar una muy
buena aproximación a la cantidad de años
en los cuales vamos a duplicar nuestro
dinero sin tener que utilizar todos
estos cálculos sin tener que utilizar
logaritmo etcétera etcétera lo que nos
va a ayudar la regla de 72 es encontrar
una aproximación más cercana
por ejemplo fíjense en esto nosotros
teníamos en el ejercicio anterior un 10%
de interés compuesto anual tenemos un
10% de interés compuesto anual y nos
preguntábamos en cuánto tiempo vamos a
hacer que nuestro dinero sea el doble y
nos salió que aproximadamente eras 7.3
ahora bien con la regla de 72 lo único
que hay que hacer es dividir el número
72 entre la cantidad de porcentaje o lo
que es lo mismo la tasa de interés
compuesto anual y esto nos dará una gran
aproximación a la cantidad de años en la
cual se duplica nuestro dinero en este
caso 72 entre 10 es 7.2 años recuerden
que estamos viendo en el caso del que
tenemos el 10% de interés compuesto
anual y fíjense que no estábamos tan
lejos de la realidad nosotros habíamos
obtenido con el otro método 7.3 años y
aquí la aproximación es de 7.2 años así
de fácil y así de sencillo ahora bien si
ustedes hace sorprendente esta regla
pero todavía no creen que sirva para
cualquier porcentaje entonces vamos a
cambiar el porcentaje a ver qué es lo
que pasa
supongamos que tengo el 6% de interés
compuesto anual entonces por la regla de
72 yo voy a tener 72 dividido entre la
cantidad de porcentaje que es 6 y 72
entre 6 es lo mismo que 12 entonces en
12 años se va a duplicar nuestro dinero
si nosotros tenemos una tasa del 6% de
interés anual
y bueno esto es nosotros utilizamos la
regla del 72
es decir si utilizamos esa cierta
aproximación y ahora para saber qué tan
lejos estamos de la realidad o no vamos
a resolver la ecuación correspondiente
que nos quedaría el logaritmo en base de
diez dedos y ojos siempre es dos porque
nosotros queremos duplicar nuestro
dinero entre el logaritmo en base 10 de
quien pues necesitamos ver cuánto es uno
más
el porcentaje si cuando teníamos el 10
por ciento era 1.1 cuando tenemos el 6%
va a ser un 1.06 y ahora si saquemos la
calculadora y el logaritmo de 2 es igual
a punto 30 10 dividido entre el
logaritmo de 1.06 y esto va a ser igual
a
11.89 entonces esto es aproximadamente
11.9 y ya está se dan cuenta no
estábamos tan lejos del resultado que me
dio al usar la regla de 72 pues darse
cuenta que con la regla de 72 obtuvimos
12 años mientras con el cálculo real es
de 11.9 años las diferencias mínimas
aquí es donde se da cuenta 1 que la
aproximación con la regla de 72 es
bastante buena y además es muy rápida
comparación de todos los cálculos que
podemos hacer con los logaritmos y es
por eso que me tomé la libertad de hacer
las dos gráficas comparando lo que pasa
con la regla de 72 y lo que pasa con
esta ecuación que tenemos aquí variando
los porcentajes y las tasas de interés
desde el 1 hasta el 25% ok y vamos a ver
que tenemos aquí en la primera columna
yo tengo la cantidad de tiempo en la
cual se duplica mi inversión inicial
utilizando la ecuación de los logaritmos
es decir la cantidad de tiempo real en
la cual se duplica mi dinero en la
segunda columna yo tengo la aproximación
utilizando la regla del 72 en la cual se
duplica mi dinero y en la tercera
columna yo tengo mi taza de interés
multiplicada por la cantidad
en la cual se duplica y ahora si vamos a
ver qué columna corresponde a que
grafica la primera columna es la gráfica
que está pintada de azul es la gráfica
actual vamos a llamarla esta en cuenta
empieza a cerca del 4% en el 4% valía
17.67 entonces el 4% vale 17.67 que es
más o menos por aquí es este punto que
tenemos aquí después puse el 5% que el
5% se dan cuenta es 14.21 14.21 aquí
está entonces es este punto de aquí de
ese cuenta que son tres años menos y es
que no hay que olvidar que estamos
hablando de duplicar dinero y es más
miren cuando tenemos el uno por ciento
de interés compuesto anual nosotros
tardamos 70 años casi 70 años en
duplicar nuestro dinero y cuando
nosotros aumentamos al 2% de interés
compuesto anual baja hasta 36 años en
duplicar nuestro dinero ahora vamos a
ver qué gráfica le corresponde a la
segunda columna la segunda columna le
voy a ponerte rojo pues es la gráfica
que está pintada de rojo y esta
corresponde a la aproximación en la que
el tiempo que vamos a duplicar nuestro
dinero utilizando la regla del 72 y
recuerden que esta sale de dividir el 72
entre la cantidad del porcentaje por
ejemplo aquí tenemos 72 entre el 4% lo
cual nos va a dar 18 18 años en duplicar
nuestro dinero mientras que el valor
verdadero es de 17 puntos 67 años nada
mal después puse las dos gráficas en un
mismo plano para que se den cuenta que
no están nada lejos la una de la otra si
se dan cuenta antes de este punto en la
regla de 72 están ligeramente
sobreestimada a los valores de la
gráfica del valor verdadero mientras que
después de este punto la gráfica de la
regla de 72 está subestimada ligeramente
subestimada de los valores de la gráfica
del valor verdadero y bueno tal vez se
están preguntando por qué 72 tiene que
ser ese número mágico por lo tanto lo
que hice en la tercera columna es
multiplicar la tasa de interés por la
cantidad de tiempo en el cual se
duplicaba nuestro dinero y se dan cuenta
va desde 69 hasta 77 casi 78 por ciento
es por eso que 72 es un buen número
porque es un número que está en medio de
estas 2
y además para valores de tasa de interés
desde el 1 hasta el 25 72 es un buen
número y de hecho creo que les va a
servir bastante en su vida cotidiana
porque al final si algún día invertimos
una cierta cantidad de dinero con esta
regla podremos saber en cuánto tiempo se
va a duplicar nuestra inversión inicial
de una manera rápida y sencilla así que
vamos a hacer un último ejemplo para que
vean lo rápido y sencillo que es si
nosotros queremos saber en cuánto tiempo
se duplica nuestro dinero con una tasa
de interés del 9 por ciento por lo tanto
hay que dividir 72 entre 9 lo cual me da
una cantidad de tiempo aproximada de 8
años y si comparamos este resultado de
ocho años con el resultado del valor
verdadero nos vamos a dar cuenta que el
resultado del valor verdadero es de 8.04
en 8.04 años se duplica nuestro dinero
por lo tanto tenemos una muy buena
aproximación